Super Bowl was not all that bad I am
told I I didn't even make it to halftime
I left I had to get the kids to sleep I
had to do some work so I left early but
I did see some clips of halftime and the
big story from halftime is that Rihanna
who is the performer is pregnant
which I thought was great you know that
the guys who organized the Super Bowl
were Furious about this because they
they signed the contract I assumed
before Rihanna got pregnant certainly
before Rihanna was showing that she was
pregnant
there hadn't been a big announcement
that this singer was pregnant and so
they say oh no we got this
pregnant we hate pregnancy we hate kids
there's overpopulation we got we got
we're pushing abortion our singers
pregnant now she's probably not gonna
do is like a weird sexually
charged dance that would be really
because that would be pretty awkward
wouldn't it the show it was one of the
tamest halftime shows we've seen in
years
and people were celebrating probably not
the organizers of the Super Bowl but
everybody else they said they were so
happy for Rihanna as they should have
been uh Philip Lewis
who is an editor for The Huffington Post
he's the senior front page editor he
tweeted out he said Rihanna performed
the Super Bowl halftime show while
pregnant with second child
representative confirms
my first reaction was
it's a child again is it
that's amazing because I was told
previously
I was reliably informed by the sort of
people who work at The Huffington Post
that when a baby is in the womb it's not
a baby it's not a child
it's not alive it's not human it's just
a meaningless clump of cells
certainly we are told that when poor
women get pregnant
that that's a meaningless clump of cells
you should go kill that so you can get
back to work at the widget Factory
certainly we are told that when
desperate women who do not have
adequate support to raise a child
without some degree of difficulty and
suffering when they get pregnant oh you
should just go kill it you're not even
killing it it's not even a baby just go
it's a simple medical procedure it's a
clump of cells don't even look at it
it's okay just get it done but then when
Rihanna is pregnant well that's one
that's a child
it's a child when wealthy people want
babies
and they get pregnant then that's a
child the royal baby whenever a duchess
gets pregnant it's never the Royal fetus
it's never the Royal clump of cells it's
always the Royal babies going to be born
in six months
it's just when poor people when the
deplorables when the irredeemables when
the bitter clinging Bible thumping no
good useless people like some
contributors to the world economic Forum
calls them when they get pregnant when
you get pregnant
then you should kill it nobody wants
that Rihanna though that's great I'm
glad I'm glad even The Huffington Post
can admit it that's a great that's a
great new change speaking of things
growing inside of people great news for
John fetterman the senator from
Pennsylvania the gigantic bulbous uh
growth on his neck has apparently gone
away
this was one of the reasons that John
Federman was wearing a lot of hoodies
during the campaign is he had this giant
very concerning growth on his neck but
John Federman didn't want to ask any or
answer rather any questions about his
health while he was on the campaign
Trail and so they just kind of covered
it up as best they could and now the
growth is gone which I'm sure is
actually a very very good thing
but John fetterman continues to have
health problems uh we we saw over the
last week John Federman was admitted to
the hospital George Washington
University hospital because he was
feeling light-headed at a fundraiser
John Federman thought that he might be
having another stroke apparently and so
they went in gave him a CT CTA MRI tests
they ruled out a stroke which is good
news his EEG tests came back normal
and no evidence of any seizures which
they had been concerned about but John
fetterman is not doing well back in the
fall John Federman was talking about
football he was talking about the Eagles
who were in the Super Bowl and here here
was here was a pretty
simple answer about football that he
tried to formulate
pickles
are so much better
than Eagles
no no
okay
so presumably he was trying to say the
Eagles are better than the Steelers or
the Steelers are better than the Eagles
who didn't obviously didn't come out
very well I really am not making fun of
the guy the guy obviously has brain
damage and continues to have that the
New York Times is reporting on that the
New York Times reported that Federman
has been left with quote serious mental
health issues he often cannot understand
the words that other people are saying
as a result of the stroke he has to use
live audio to text transcription for
everything that he does
certainly in his work as a senator and
then apparently when fetterman is under
stress and being a national level
politician is a stressful job he says
that trying to understand what other
people are saying is like quote trying
to make out the muffled voice of the
teacher in the Peanuts cartoon whose
words could never be deciphered
according to this report in the times so
really bad situation it is cruel that
the libs have put him into the Senate
and that his wife is tolerating this
it's cruel because it is allowing him to
be humiliated every single day not by
mean right-wing comedians not by gotcha
journalists just he has to speak
sometimes as a U.S senator and it is
humiliating because he isn't able to to
form coherent sentences if you've ever
known a stroke victim you know this is
this is heartbreaking when when people
want to say something and they can't say
something or when they can't quite
understand what people are saying to
them and so
many people are are observing that this
man is not fit to be a U.S senator
and that's the only part that I disagree
with
I agree that it's cruel and wrong to put
him in the U.S Senate I think his family
should be ashamed of themselves I think
the Democratic party should be ashamed
of itself
for many other reasons but that one too
but he's not unfit to be a senator
because he doesn't really have to do
anything as a senator
his staff can just vote for him
a hundred years ago being a senator
meant more than it does today 200 years
ago being a senator certainly meant more
than it does today
a lot of the Senate's power is just gone
though and the Senate and the House of
Representatives have just shipped that
power away to bureaucrats in the
executive agencies to the leadership in
the Senate and leadership in the House
of Representatives to
to International supernational bodies
that control a lot of U.S policy
they've just given it away and it was
their right to give it away I know there
are some people who are real antagonists
of the administrative State and the real
small government conservatives and they
say the Congress had no right to
delegate away these Powers but I'm not
convinced by that necessarily
I think the Congress has brought power
to delegate away its responsibilities
and it has all the incentive to because
if Congress and the Senate are voting on
legislation then it's going to open them
up to attacks
if they say well we're only voting on
one or two bills a year we're going to
vote on the Omnibus we're going to vote
on a defense authorization act and
that's pretty much all we're going to do
all year long then it becomes much
easier to go back and campaign and if
that's all you're voting on then then
this guy is just going to be a rubber
stamp in fact even before the stroke he
was running to be a rubber stamp it's
not as though John Federman was a road
scholar okay it's not as though the
health problems are really what
exacerbated John federman's dissent into
this lowest common denominator politics
he was always going to be a rubber stamp
for the whatever the Democrats wanted
and that's what he is now
foreign
[Music]